- [Mark] All right, Haley.
Haley, where are you from?
Where did you grow up?
- I'm from Pennsylvania,
but I grew up all over the place,
'cause I was an army family.
And so when I left home about 15,
I ran away with an Outlaw Biker
and then we moved to Arizona.
And-
- [Mark] You ran away at 15?
- Yup, when I was 15. Yeah.
- [Mark] Tell me about your
family, your childhood.
- Well, I had a problem with,
calling my stepdad "Dad"
and so I wasn't the greatest daughter.
I had some problems in school,
they put me in adaptive
behavior and stuff like that.
- [Mark] You guys just didn't get along?
- Huh?
- Yeah, we didn't get along that well.
But, he was a good provider.
And so anyway...
- [Mark] But no abuse, no crazy...
- What's that?
- [Mark] No abuse, no like sexual or-
- No sexual abuse. No sexual abuse.
Really no abuse.
And now, my real dad was kind
of abusive, but not sexually.
- [Mark] So you got married at what age?
- I got married at 15.
- [Mark] Wow.
- I told my parents if they
ever wanted to see me again
that they would sign consent forms,
so I could be married
and get my independence early.
And so at 16 I was
married with a new baby.
And we moved to Arizona,
and I was married for about three years.
And then from there...
- [Mark] With the biker?
- Huh?
- With the biker guy, yes.
And he was my legal guardian.
Then from there, I left
him for another biker guy,
in a Motorcycle Gang
called The Dirty Dozen.
And then, he put me in a strip club.
So I worked as a stripper
for three months,
and he didn't even come back
to pick me up that night.
So I had to find my way back
to my new place to live.
And then he slapped me 'cause
I wouldn't go to Sturgis.
And I broke up with him, left him,
but still worked for the strip club.
- [Mark] He did what?
- He slapped me in front of a brother
because I wouldn't go to Sturgis.
- [Mark] The big biker rally?
- A big biker rally, yes.
- [Mark] Up in Sturgis, North Dakota...
South Dakota.
- Yes, yes.
And then so, but I still was a stripper
for a few more months.
And then from there I
worked at a race car shop
called Well Tech fabrications,
and I had to build a
little race car parts.
And then my boss there cut me a check
to go get an apartment.
And so I got one above a
bar called The Road House,
where you can come down and play pool
and drink beer and stuff like that.
And it was a really cool
two-bedroom apartment
with pink carpet.
And so I did that for a while,
I was on probation and violated it.
Then I finally got my stuff
together a little bit,
but-
- [Mark] Probation for what?
- Worked for ampm.
It was for a joint.
- [Mark] Okay.
- And so I had to do three
years probation for that
and I worked for ampm, and
then I found my true love.
I was in love for a few years,
and then I left him cause he,
I had to buy a chocolate
cake and a bottle of wine.
- Will you slow down?
You're hurrying so you can make your bus
in about 20 minutes but
we're gonna do fine.
'Cause the bus station's literally
three blocks down the street.
So your true love was your third.
- Yes. Yes.
He was my third-
- [Mark] Was he a biker as well?
- He was not, he was from
actually Cedar Rapids, Iowa.
But he lived in Arizona and
he was like my dream guy.
He was like the dirty
blonde hair, blue eyes,
no hair on the chest, chain cross.
And yeah, love at first sight.
It was a fairytale love story.
And anyway, I bought a chocolate
cake and a bottle of wine,
to ask him if he was in
love with me one day,
'cause I turned into a nice boring girl,
'cause I was on probation
and pay bills and work.
And so when he said, "No.",
it kind of broke my heart.
And so I sang every one
of the Kurt Cobain songs
in the middle of my living room.
And pretty much manifested my
future going to Washington.
Didn't know Kurt Cobain was
from there in Washington.
Didn't learn that 'til five years later.
But then after I was there,
I moved into from Arizona
in 1999, came to Washington in
2000 to see my stepdad retire
from the military.
And then I got stuck
there for 20 years because
they went back to the east
coast and I stayed there.
I was dating a guy,
A new guy with a 93
anniversary model Corvette.
And so I just stayed behind, stayed there.
And then I got a lot of jobs at first,
but then 2005 came and I
got involved in the meth.
And then I went 15 years without working,
thought I was gonna get
SSI, but it didn't happen.
And then I found out the
dirty little secret of Olympia
which was the heroin, that
people are on heroin there.
Some of my friends died over the years.
The longest people I've
ever known in my life
lived there in Olympia, Washington.
And some of them were heroin addicts
and I come across dead
bodies all the time.
Not too long ago, about three months ago,
a friend of mine was behind
the Shell gas station,
all creeped up against the wall.
He had a 211 in one hand
and a rig in the other
and he had just died back there.
It was somebody that I knew
from one of my boyfriends,
that I had when I first
started out in Washington.
- [Mark] Is this is
fentanyl that's doing this?
- What's that?
- [Mark] Is this fentanyl,
that's doing this?
- I think so, yeah, probably
I've never gotten into it.
I don't like it, but I do use meth.
I smoke marijuana and...
But I can still work.
I'm not disabled enough to work.
And so I don't take any medication,
I just work and get, try
and get my stuff together.
So anyway, I'm currently homeless
in the Decatur Woods on
the West side of Olympia.
- [Mark] Washington?
- Yeah in Washington, and
the people I've known there,
I've known for a few years.
And so it's kinda cool in a way
and I'm in survival mode.
But once I'm able to get to
where I can come from that tent
and go look for a job and
get my stuff together...
'Cause I'm all on my own.
I have no family help,
no resources of any sort.
- [Mark] How do you support yourself?
- I support myself unfortunately,
by prostituting a little bit,
with two people only.
And I've known these
two people for 15 years.
- [Mark] So, you have two solid regulars?
- Yes, and then I also paint prep.
And then recently I had a
job for five months at ampm,
and I didn't...
Be a homeless and living
in a garage because,
one friend of mine-
- [Mark] Do your two regulars
know about each other?
- No they do not.
They do now.
With this video which
will appear on YouTube.
They might find out.
- They might (Laughs)
- [Mark] You'll have to get a new one.
- Probably so.
But anyway, yeah,
and so I'm currently here
in California right now.
'Cause I came out here
with two friends of mine
that promised me a job,
doing some sort of job.
He tears down stores and hop on...
sound planes, goes to stores,
tears them down and gets paid for it.
I was coming along to do it too.
I was gonna be working for 15 days,
but it didn't work out.
You know...
We used some meth, you know,
we got a hotel, but all
of a sudden they upset me
and I slammed the door
and kicked the trashcan.
And then the guy told the lady that I was
destroying the hotel, which I wasn't.
And so he wouldn't let me back in.
And I was out there all night long
and in a town I have
never even been at before.
And I couldn't say anything, you know.
I couldn't do anything.
I couldn't bring any heat
and so I was trying to wait in the truck
and the guy comes and he goes,
"You can't wait in the back of the truck."
And I go, "Well, I came
here in this truck."
and he goes, "You can't wait
here in the back of the truck."
And I said, "Okay, well
can I wait outside?"
He goes, "As long as you
don't cause any problems."
So I said, "Okay."
But they never came down from the hotel
to come get me or anything.
So from that point, I
had to make a decision.
Because he did give me
$200 to get a ticket back.
And so I got my ticket right here.
And then I just kinda wandered off
where I met a friend of mine.
That he brought me here to meet you.
And then, so yeah.
I got ahead and wait a whole night to-
- [Mark] So you spent
the night on Skid Row?
- What's that?
- [Mark] You spent the night on Skid Row?
- On Skid Row, yes.
- [Mark] How was that?
- It was interesting.
It was interesting-
- [Mark] How does it compare to your
Olympia Washington's campground?
- Well, they have a
mitigation center down there
in downtown Olympia.
Where it's fenced off where all the people
that are homeless are.
And then there's the Decatur woods where
there's people there that
they don't let anybody in.
You know, it's just
like a posse of people.
I'm with some friends of mine actually.
And yeah, they're kinda cool.
And I've been there five years off and on
in the Decatur Woods.
So it was a cougar that was
spotted on my campsite recently.
And so that's the only thing
I'm worried about, mainly.
That my tent's still gonna
be standing when I get there.
'Cause it's a big one, you know.
It's all nice and clean
and everything like that.
And I ride the trail.
- [Mark] Your child is with your-
- What's that?
- [Mark] You have children?
- Yes, my son is with his, well...
he's grown now he's 27.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
- And he's a semi-truck driver
and he owns his own semi-truck.
- [Mark] Oh, he's all grown up?
- Yes. Yes.
Very good kid.
Yeah. Unfortunately he
doesn't want anything to do
with me right now.
I don't know why, but I think
he's getting another story,
you know, from somebody else or whatever.
But I'm a great person,
you know what I mean?
I've had some fall downs and
stuff throughout my life.
I've been on and off, you know,
drugs, but nothing serious.
But I'm a good-hearted person.
I help people out every day.
And, I'm just a lovely
person to be around.
Regardless of-
- [Mark] Is stopping
crystal meth, an option?
- Yeah.
I don't really consider myself an addict
or a fiend or anything like that.
I'm just a consumer, cause I don't buy it.
I just have a lot of friends that do it.
Like all my friends now that I've known
for 15 years out of my life to 20 years,
they're all convicts and
people that use meth.
So I get it for free.
They just get, you know, just get me high
for free and I can take it or leave it.
I'm not an addict.
- [Mark] And so the men in your life...
Right now, you're single?
- Yes, I am.
I'm single right now.
I wanted to go back to Arizona
to reunite with my true love.
'Cause I thought maybe I
could possibly get him back.
Because I'm young and beautiful
and I got the nicest ass
in this, you know, the
whole town I believe.
And I saved it for him for
this particular person, Todd.
Who I'm still in love with today.
I've not been able to find
another guy quite like him.
I can't get involved
with in a relationship.
He's just the one.
And so I've not been able to contact him.
I know where he lives
at and stuff like that
but I haven't had the
money yet to go see him.
And so, but yeah, I'm
in Olympia, Washington.
And, so hopefully he'll
give me a call, someday.
It's 3609 (silence) four.
(laughing)
- [Mark] This is a little
love note on YouTube.
- So what time is it?
Are we good on our time?
- [Mark] We are.
Yeah. You got about five, seven minutes.
- That's crazy.
Because the time out there flies by.
And out here the time goes by super slow.
- [Mark] We're literally two minutes away.
So-
- Yeah. Yeah.
That's what he said to
two minutes away, yeah.
But, yeah, and anything
else you wanna ask me?
- [Mark] So I mean, your
childhood experience
with your stepdad, did you
think that kind of paved the way
for your whole lifestyle
which is kind of like,
(ambulance siren)
you know-
- What's that?
- [Mark] Your lifestyle of like bikers
and strip clubs.
- Bikers. Yep.
We were in a motorcycle club
called The Equestrians in Texas.
And then I went from MC to MG
with a Dirty Dozen Biker guy.
Then I was a stripper and
never told my mom that.
She'll probably know now, but yeah.
But then I worked for ampm for three years
and walked away from it all my true love,
my job and my son to come
see my stepdad retire
from the military here or
up there in Washington.
And then I was waiting for a bus
coming from a tanning salon one day
and this 93 white
anniversary model Corvette
comes rolling down and I looked
up at the sky and I said,
"Please don't let this
guy turn around please."
And he did, he turned around
and I got in and I really,
really liked that car.
It was a whole reason why-
- [Mark] So he was
picking you up on a date
in the street?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I was just waiting
for a bus after tanning
in a tanning salon.
- [Mark] So a stranger just came up
and picked you up in his Corvette?
- Yeah, yeah. And I got in,
and then I dated that guy
for about a year and a half,
and he spent like $30,000 on me
in the first year and a
half we were together.
And I had a lot of jobs, you
know, and stuff like that.
But then I punched him
on the freeway, got...
A cop saw me do that
and had my first trip to
the Thurston County Jail.
And then our relationship was over.
Then I kinda went on my own
and discovered Olympia by myself.
And met another boyfriend who
I stayed with for five years.
And I stayed there for
15 years in Washington,
in Olympia on my own, after I left him,
because I was with him
for about five years.
It was like a dope house I lived at.
And I met a lot of friends of mine
which I know today are still there.
And like I said, a couple of them died
because they were on heroin.
And yeah, I don't like that drug.
It's terrible.
- [Mark] Did you think
your somewhat alternative
lifestyle is a little bit crazy lifestyle?
This may have been what
tore that relationship apart
that you're longing for?
- I think the reason
why my crazy lifestyle
and the reason why I got stuck
in Washington was because
well, for one, when 2005 came,
I didn't really know what I wanted to do.
And so living at the dope house,
I did start using meth again.
And I actually knew a couple
of Hell's Angels as well.
I've got a tattoo right
here, which is a free tattoo.
He's not around anymore.
He passed away, but he owned
his own three tattoo shops
Sacred, Studio 81 and Old School Tattoos.
- [Mark] Let's see that tattoo.
Yup. It's a Playboy bunny
tattoo and she's looking back.
I've always wanted to be a Playboy bunny.
I was supposed to get a boob job
and I got a cherry tattoo
right here on my...
Right there.
- [Mark] You sure do.
- I have a nice butt.
(laughing)
(object clunks on floor)
The nicest butt you'll ever see.
But I was supposed to get a boob job.
In February 14th of last
year and it didn't happen.
It kind of bummed me out
because once I got that
then I've got it all in my eyes.
And I'll be in love with myself.
And I think that that alone
is gonna make me, you know,
it's gonna make me secure
in my relationship.
And I'm gonna probably pursue trying to
get my true love back there in Arizona
while I'm young and beautiful.
And probably live out the
rest of my life there.
- [Mark] So your boob
job will win your man?
- I believe so.
I believe so.
- [Mark] I've had
girlfriends do that to me.
It's done the opposite.
(laughing)
Every guy is different.
- [Haley] I know.
And every guy I've talked to,
they liked the boobs I have.
And I'm the only one
that doesn't like them.
You know what I mean?
It's just me.
- [Mark] It works both ways.
- [Haley] Yes, yes it does.
It does.
- [Mark] All right, Haley.
Well, I wish you the best of luck.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Let me take
you to the bus station.
So you don't miss your bus.
- Thank you.
Thank you for the interview.
- [Mark] Very interesting story.
Thank you very much.
- [Haley] Have a good day.
(laughing)
- [Mark] So tell me about
your night on Skid Row,
who did you meet?
- [Haley] I forget what his name was.
But he was definitely an LA
boy and he promised me...
First he said he wanted to smoke some weed
with me or sell me some weed.
And then all of a sudden it changed up
and he wanted to smoke some weed with me.
But then he never did.
And then he mentioned something about
I may have to go sell my
pussy or something like that.
I said, "No, I'm just killing time."
And I got a bus ticket outta
here and stuff like that.
And then, so this other guy
gave me my first crack hit.
I was sitting right there.
And then that's when Corey came up-
- [Mark] And that's how it all starts.
- Yeah, that's how it all starts.
Yeah-
- [Mark] The next day,
you know, you're down here
and you're-
- Oh, man.
- [Mark] You got a pimp.
- Yeah, that.
I wasn't gonna be doing that,
and so Corey came up and-
- [Mark] He saved you.
- Yeah, he saved me.
He totally saved me.
- [Mark] He's a good guy.
(laughing)
See, that's my buddy.
- [Haley] Yup.